sabi sabi sabi e allora cosa ti avevo
detto di non farlo ma cosa ma cosa ma
che stai farà 2000 calcagni
ma quando mai mi capita di fare un video
con gli addobbi io continuo a farlo
all'infinito così è simpaticissimo ma
cosa vuoi l'hanno chiesto cinque minuti
per fare il video 5 no pensavo siccome
sei facendo un video su spider man
magari due cosine potevo dirle anch'io
così è giusto per ma non ci penso
proprio
ma neanche mezza informazione dammi una
buona ragione per cui dovrei fallito con
te è casa mia
ok
[Musica]
o spider man se il supereroe più amato
di tutti
nato nel 1962 tasselli e silvi co
inizialmente il personaggio non nasceva
sotto i migliori auspici
infatti è stato inserito nell'ultimo
numero di una testata che sapeva già che
avrebbe chiuso amazing fantasy numero 15
e invece è successo fu abnorme tanto che
di lì a poco nacque la testata amazing
spider man e da lì telefilm cartoni
videogiochi un sacco di roba bella
tralasciando l'episodio pilota della
serie del 1977 con nicolas enbom passata
solo dopo come film arriviamo ai tre
film diretti da sembra limits
bisogna ammetterlo la sede di raimi è
stata capace di farci vedere il lato
classico della serie d uomo ragno e i
rapporti tra i vari comprimari ma adesso
piaciuti film si anche il terzo ma
proprio comi e ti pareva
quello che vogliamo presentarvi oggi è
una perla rarissima nel panorama della
cinematografia e nella primissima
trasposizione live action del
personaggio di spiderman datata 1969
diretto ed interpretato da donald club è
un cortometraggio di dieci minuti
amatoriale fino allo sfinimento degli
effetti così speciali credetemi non li
avete mai visti
[Musica]
il corto inizia a new york in cui viene
inquadrato un giornale scienziato
sfigurato diventa dottor lightning chi
schifo e il dottor lightning
non ne ho idea quando vediamo la
ragnatela del nostro eroe acchiapparlo
se è tra l'altro più che ragnatela
sembra la rete con cui pescatori pescato
il como insuperabile 170 grammi di bontà
in olio d'oliva
fermiamoci un attimo secondo te come
potrebbero mai rappresentare la scena di
spiderman aggrappato al muro in un film
amatoriale del 69
eh sì potrebbe che ne so far sdraiare un
nuovo sul pavimento dipingere il
pavimento come se fosse un muro e poi
capovolgere l'inquadratura ingenuo
commesso un meglio e ho notato ma
parliamo un attimo del costume
una cosa che ha fatto storcere il naso a
parecchi fan della saga cinematografica
di rahimi e dell'imminente reboot e la
resa del costume nella serie di larini
sembrava poco credibile un costume con
le ragnatele in rilievo in quello
attuale sembra essere fatto non lo so
con un pallone da basket
beh questo accontenterà tutti i puristi
i puristi di cosa del 3x2 al lidl ma
guardalo anche nella mia terra e sotto
le ascelle come lo disegnava silvi col
mitico steve ditko ma torniamo a noi
ci spostiamo al daily bugle o quello che
può passare per tale con un foglio
bianco con scritto daily bugle capisco
la sospensione dell'incredulità ma qua
veramente si sta esagerando non è che
adesso io metto un cartello segreto
vaticano davanti camera mia e siamo in
santa sede cioè per favore un rapinatore
entra in uno degli uffici per rapire una
ragazza la figlia del dottor lightning
no tra l'altro bellissima la mascherina
veramente ci piace tanto nel catalogo
online sotto la categoria porno
amatoriale e tu come lo sai
continuando spiderman percepisce il
pericolo ed entra in azione ha
finalmente non vedo l'ora
[Musica]
possiamo rivederla no rivediamola
[Applauso]
e la cosa più spettacolare dai tempi di
bird eric possiamo andare avanti
sei sicuro no ma peggio di così il ladro
fugge in auto con l'ostaggio mentre il
nostro amichevole pupazzo di quartiere
si arrampica sul muro highmore sembra
uno di quei pupazzetti che legavano
nelle patatine degli anni 90 parte
l'inseguimento il manigoldo scappa del
deserto tra l'altro io sarò anche
tignoso ma mi spiegate dove cacchio sta
lanciando le ragnatele che si trova nel
deserto del missouri come cavolo l'ha
inseguito passato per la città nel
deserto dove cacchio l'attaccava se
magna del scusami ma tu come gli sfondi
alla gente che ti chiede come fa
superman non essere riconosciuto solo
perché porta gli occhiali non farti
domanda esatto qui è uguale
finalmente siamo arrivati all'incontro
con il temibile dottor lightning bene
così vediamo a chi è ispirato quali sono
i suoi poteri e dove esce fuori
sono proprio curioso gli uomo scrat
mentre per i maschi a gennaro e di
testing and roll flash
ma tralasciando la voce che sembra sia
il cameraman a parlare chi è chi è
llodra priming è chi è il dottor live
chiedo torace ed è una versione farlo
chi si ma del dottor destino in tenuta
estiva con neanche il cappuccio con la
maschera di ferro che già due parafanghi
al posto delle orecchie sembra waze
mitrano proprio mamma mia che pecionata
labari shiki pezza bella anche questa
scena che trasuda amatorialità da tutti
i pixel
il nostro eroe con balzo felino e musica
in pieno stile porno soft le raggiunge e
inizia lo scontro con il sicario
mancano solo le onomatopee e poi
sembrano i combattimenti del film di
batman quello con adam west non so se
avete presente
certi giorni non riesci a liberarti di
una bomba signore concederà la lotta
senza esclusione di colpi
quando ad un tratto intervie nell'oscuro
poter del dottor lightning della sua
temibile arma dovrebbero essere fulmini
quelle poco fulmini o sta preparando col
suo terribile pastamatic un piatto di
linguine al pesto di noci fatto sta che
colpisce il suo seguace e lo frigge
credo senza effetti è difficile capire
spara un secondo colpo e questa volta
centra spiderman che cade a terra con
movenze molto poco eroiche malara clide
non demorde e riesce a tirare una
radiospia sull'auto del dottore il ragno
spia per chi non lo sapesse sono dei
dispositivi creati dall'uomo ragno per
poter trovare in un secondo momento
attraverso il senso di ragno i manigoldi
a cui appunto veniva attaccata questa
spia
giuro più guardo queste scene ed io
penso che questo accordo fosse soltanto
una operazione commerciale per farti
comprare i pezzi di spagna dopo
attaccandomi
spider man jon spaihts riesce a
raggiungerlo cattura la macchina con una
ragnatela e la blocca su di una rupe
e qui è facile immaginare il classico
finale buonista dei fumetti degli anni
70 ma sì sicuramente lo catturerà
segnerà la giustizia lui si pentirà non
abbiamo capito se si è suicidato o se
solo un idiota che si è sparato per
sbaglio finale macabri ssimo però sono
speranzoso sono positivo perché come la
tradizione del fumetto supereroistico ci
insegna sicuramente un cattivo di peso
come dottor line verrà resuscitato
[Musica]
bene
quindi questo era spider man il primo
live action mai fatto fra vuoi
aggiungere qualcosa e ci vediamo ad una
prossima recensione che sarà un'altra
chicca sempre dell'uomo ragno ma ci sono
di nuovo anch'io
no mi spiace
salvi youtubers san vito e allora cosa
che chiedendo se la gente che so perché
io non metto ma deciso che il signore è
molto importante